Oh no!
I forgot tea!
I forgot to get a drink!
Oh well.
It's been a couple of days.
Did you miss me?
You have customers.
They're... they're doing their own thing.
They told me... I walked over there and I was just like, would you like me to serve you?
And they said, actually, please don't come over here.
Don't even look at us.
Don't even bother us.
So don't worry about it.
I think they're... I think they're up to no good.
Hey Mint, yes I miss you.
Yippee!
Sorry, we're booked for a private event.
Yeah, exactly.
Thank you!
Oh wait, hold on.
Welcome back, boss.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I went away.
Actually, if you listen to the...
If you listen... well...
Maybe for some people, you already know.
I talked about it in the podcast a little bit.
I went to...
Did you miss us?
Yeah.
Is that Jerma in your cafe?
Is that what Jerma looks like?
I don't think Jerma has glasses.
That's Jerma.
I talked about it a little bit on the podcast if you listened.
If you listened today, thank you for listening.
If you haven't listened to it yet, thank you for listening to it in the future.
And if you are... haven't listened to it, why not?
Thank you!
And the waitress is too shy and introverted to call out the customers bringing outside food into the cafe.
Wait, you're not allowed to do?
Bring outside food?
Thank you for the red soup!
Inspired me to go to a con recently.
It's a lot of fun and even though I didn't cosplay, I felt like a fish out of water.
I still have fun recognizing and taking pictures with several cosplayers.
Now I'm planning what I want to cosplay as next time I go.
Let's go!
Wait, where did you go?
Where did you go?
I'm sure those things are the 10 gifted.
And blind bot, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I was at the dentist during the podcast, that's why.
You should have listened to it with your dentist.
They would have been like...
Oh my god, they would have had a hold on your teeth.
They would have grabbed it.
They would have gripped it.
They would have firmly grasped it.
They would have been like...
Listening to it and just gripping your teeth.
In anticipation of what we were talking about.
The dentist would have said...
Based?
Maybe.
I don't know.
But yeah, I've talked about it.
I've said this like three times now.
Talked about it a little bit on the podcast.
And I went to a convention.
I went to Anime Central.
And I made a surprise appearance at Ayami Sensei's panel.
It was so last minute.
Oh my gosh.
It was extremely last minute.
Surprise?
Question mark, question mark, question mark.
Okay, it was a surprise.
Because there was no plan for me to be in that panel.
Until...
Maybe like ten minutes before the panel.
And then...
Ayami Sensei called to me.
She was like, Mito-chan!
Join my panel!
And I was like...
Is it okay?
Because...
It's your panel.
Like, you're the guest.
I felt really bad.
I was like, you're the guest.
People are coming to see you.
Not me.
And so...
That's hella last minute.
It was extremely last minute.
What was the panel about?
She tried snacks.
American snacks.
So...
Some of them I gave to her and some of them were given by fans.
So I saw someone say that they didn't get the meet and greet tickets were off, Kai.
I'm sorry.
I think I've seen several people saying that.
I've seen...
I've seen very few people saying that they've gotten tickets and more people saying that they didn't get tickets.
Welcome back!
We might have missed you or something.
Thank you.
Sold out already?
No, no!
They weren't...
They weren't sold.
They were a...
A lottery.
Actually, it's funny because...
When I...
I mentioned to Sensei, to Ayami Sensei that...
Her meet and greet...
Her autograph session at Anime Central also sold out.
Which I didn't get.
I don't know.
I say sold out, but they were free, I'm pretty sure.
But...
When I showed her that, I was like, they're completely full.
And she was like, yeah.
Thank you!
Can't stick around, so I'll catch the vibe.
Have a good night!
Um...
Also...
Cor... Cor...
Corio...
Finis...
Bugs is like...
A...
Bug...
Don...
Nuat.
No.
Thanks, Yoko.
Um...
They were free.
They were free, right?
Most of her merch sold out.
I...
I know!
Um...
But when I showed her that, she was just like...
Actually...
So many of my fans said that they...
They didn't make it...
Into the...
Into the autograph session, so...
Who...
Who made it in?
And now I'm thinking that, I'm like...
Wait, so many people...
Are saying that they didn't make it in...
To my meet and greet, so...
Who's showing up?
Who's...
Who's gonna be there?
Poor boyfriend.
I know!
Really happy she did so well.
Me too!
It seems like she had a lot of fun.
She...
Kept thanking me a lot.
Which I was like...
You know...
I just...
I just did your panel.
I really didn't do anything.
But she...
She was saying that...
Lurkers?
Probably?
Maybe!
Who knows?
But...
Hopefully...
Even if not at the...
Official meet and greet...
Maybe we can find another way to...
Um...
To meet...
Somehow...
During the convention...
If you will be at Ofukai.
And if you won't be at Ofukai...
Maybe...
You...
I'll be at another event that you'll be going to.
So...
Mmm...
Yeah...
So...
I don't know...
Hmm...
You've got lots of fan's mint...
I don't know...
Hmm...
I'm in North...
I'll be in the parking lot!
Let's go!
Yeah...
I'll be in the parking lot!
At Adam...
At Adam in North, I'm going to be in the parking lot!
I will be singing in the parking lot...
Chuu!
Glad you had fun with Ayame-sensei this weekend.
Also congrats on your upcoming concert appearance.
I can't go but I'll be cheering you on in spirit.
Thank you!
Yes!
And that was announced too!
I will be appearing at a concert.
Thank you!
Well liked, popular person.
Heard there was a Vtuber who had their meet and greet tickets sold out but only recognized one from their chat.
So hopefully you have better luck.
Oh!
Wait!
You said... Oh sorry, hold on.
Heard that there was a Vtuber who had a meet and greet ticket sold out but only recognized one person from the chat.
What?
That's crazy.
I don't know.
Even though, you know, it is still also exciting to meet new people.
So I hope there's no one listening who's just like, I'm a lurker and I got a meet and greet.
She's not excited to meet me.
No, no.
I am still very excited.
So...
What is Otacon doing there behind you?
They're having a barbecue!
They're having a barbecue.
Don't worry about it.
Hold on, I'm gonna eat some more of my cereal.
I got Reese's Puffs!
I hope it doesn't hurt my stomach.
It should be okay.
Minto hates me.
No!
Peanut butter chocolate flavor!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Nah, I'm gonna mute.
I'm embarrassed.
Casual lurker, but sad I couldn't see you at ASEN.
Maybe next con, but yeah.
Yeah.
Sorry if you couldn't make it to the IME panel.
Like I said, it really was.
Like so last minute.
So even if it's just like...
Announced it beforehand...
There was no time beforehand...
For you...
For maybe some people to go.
So...
Sorry.
But hopefully I can go to...
Another con as an official guest.
How did the drawing go?
Oh!
I...
Did you guys...
Hold on.
Let me get the picture.
From...
From Sensei's...
Twitter?
Ayame.
Oh, good.
She's not shadow banned anymore.
At least for a while, I couldn't search her.
Thank you.
Chuu!
Save image.
Okay.
This is how the drawing came out.
LeBron James, scream if you love me.
Isn't it so cute?
She made me look so shy and cute.
And people were telling me at the end of the panel...
That...
A strange shadow happened.
I don't know...
Like that...
But when we talked...
She said she was gonna give me a hangout.
What happened?
Did she get shy?
Maybe.
Maybe she got shy.
And made me as shy as she felt.
You know?
Who knows?
The shadow had so much power.
Sussy intentions... Was it...
Was it...
A pickle shape?
What kind of shadow was it?
When people were saying that there was a sussy shadow, I was like...
What do you mean by that?
Wow!
Thank you for the Akazuba!
I'm glad you had fun at Ace and hope I'll be lucky enough to see you at Off-Kai soon!
You're so fun to see!
Even if I can't be here all the time, have a good rest of your stream!
Thank you Luna!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Haunted pickle?
Was it hedgehog shaped?
What kind of shadow if there's anybody who...
Went to the...
Anybody who went to the panel?
I assume she was like looming over you.
What do you mean looming over me?
The hedgehog?
No!
Not the hedgehog!
I was like why are you guys keep hearing of a hedgehog?
It was an incomprehension.
Oh, because I said shadow like the hedgehog.
No!
There was...
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the...
Stop please!
Thank you!
I could have been there but I got a puppy this month.
That's exciting too though, right?
Oh my gosh!
Does it pee and poo everywhere?
I love Latina Sonic.
Shadow like the hedgehog.
Yeah, I get it now.
Dogo, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh, it was sensei's shadow while you were saying no ecchi, don't lewd.
Wait, really?
Wait, actually?
Is that her impression of me?
I see.
I feel like I need to get this framed and put on my wall.
No, ecchi, don't lewd.
That doesn't sound like you.
Well, I mean, for me... I mean, I'm still embarrassed by it.
But...
I don't dislike ecchi and lewd things.
I think... I think maybe everybody knows that by now.
What was it?
Oh...
I...
I was...
Oh...
There was a booth at Anime Central that was selling...
That was selling...
Actually, there were several booths selling doujins.
I was so shocked how many there were.
And...
One of them was just like, I'm haunted...
I'm haunted by...
Something.
And I...
I...
At the time, I was just like, oh...
I'll come back for it because...
Because...
Um...
Because I didn't have a bag that could fit it.
Like, I didn't want to carry it around.
I wasn't going back to my hotel room to put it away anytime soon.
And so, I...
I...
I went back...
The next day...
And...
It was gone!
I was so surprised!
I was like...
Are ghosts in demand?
Maybe?
I think I know which one you're talking about.
Yeah, it's sold out!
Are ghosts in demand?
Yes, they are.
Oh!
They saw you eyeing it.
No!
No, no, they couldn't have.
I'm a ghost.
They couldn't have.
They couldn't have seen me.
I'm a ghost.
But I did, like, kind of haunt the booth a little bit.
I was like, oh man.
Let's see, what else?
The stuff that I bought?
I bought a blanket that also had ghosts on it.
It was so cute!
I don't know what else I bought.
I saw it!
And I was like staring at it.
I was like, I say it's a blanket, but it's like, it's very, um, let me see if I can find the artist's name, because it's so, it's, it kind of reminds me of like, it's like when I looked at it, I just felt this overwhelming sense of like, ah, Halloween!
And fall!
And it just made me so happy.
And so, I didn't even think, I just, I just bought it.
I was like, looking at it, I was like, I think I need this.
Um, where's the artist's name?
Um...
Oh, the artist's name is Julia Likes Cats.
What a good name.
And it's like a, it's like a, let me see, actually, you know what, maybe I can find it.
Julia Likes Cats.
Blanket.
I think they called it a woven tapestry.
But...
Oh, let me type tap, tapestry.
Um...
Oh!
This is it, this is it!
I found it, I found it, I found it.
Hold on, it's loading.
No, Instagram please.
Uh, oh no, I don't have Instagram.
No!
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh.
No, I can't look at the picture unless I have Instagram.
Uh...
Okay, it's gonna be like the worst, most blurry picture ever, but...
This is what it looks like.
Oh my god, it's even worse than I thought.
Look how cute this is!
I just saw it and I was like, this is so...
It's just so nice.
It's so, like, fall and...
Everything.
Isn't it cool?
It's not a bad photo.
It's kinda bad.
It's a little bad.
Yeah.
It's so cute.
So.
Mmm.
Posts app size.
Yeah, I saw, I got that.
Um...
I got some doujinshi.
I was like looking through some old doujinshi.
Some places had, like, newer ones.
I got one from Kawori because I really like that artist.
Um...
And I got...
Of course, I got Ayami doujinshi, the newer ones that I hadn't gotten yet.
Um...
Ayami sensei.
And, um...
I...
Oh, I was looking through some older ones.
And I found, like, an old catalog of, like...
Um...
From melon books.
That had, like, a bunch of...
Like, they have, like, paseri in there.
But I barely even recognize it as paseri art.
It's like...
I was like, wow, this is like a real time capsule.
And I also had an older doujinshi of another artist I like.
Uh, Kujo Ichisou.
So I got that.
And, um...
I...
There wasn't much blue archive.
I got a...
I got a little bit of blue archive.
Oh!
There is a Metal Gear print.
I got that.
And, um...
Hmm...
I think that's about it.
Oh my gosh!
Someone though...
Someone gave something to give...
Someone gave something to Ayami-sensei.
To give to me.
Which I was like...
Huh?
I was so shocked.
Because...
I was like...
No one will have anything...
Well, first of all, I didn't expect presents at all.
I didn't expect presents at all.
But also...
I...
Thought that...
There wouldn't be anything because...
Because...
You know...
I was a surprise guest at the panel.
No one even knew I was there.
But...
Um...
Someone...
Someone gave her...
A signed...
Poster of...
A signed Metal Gear poster.
Signed by Hideo Kojima.
To give to me.
I was so shocked.
And it had like a nice little note that was like...
Dear Mint...
This has been sitting in my...
In my...
What's the word?
In my closet for a long time.
I want you to use it and appreciate it.
Or like display it.
I
felt so bad though.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Um...
I felt...
Bad that...
They gave it to Ayami Sensei.
Because I was like...
Ah!
You should be giving gifts to her.
Not to me!
I wasn't even a guest.
So...
That's so cute.
It was really nice though.
Yeah.
It was a lot of fun.
And the panel was really funny.
Um...
Overall I had a good time.
Uh...
The last time I went to Anime Central...
I have been before.
The last time was...
Many years ago.
So...
I don't know.
Um...
But I've always liked the convention.
Itself.
And uh...
Unfortunately I didn't get any autographs.
So...
I...
Um...
Yeah.
I guess you were Ayami's guest.
Maybe.
I'm surprised they had it ready.
Me too!
Me...
Actually though.
I was so shocked.
And...
Many years ago.
Wow!
Old!
That was years ago.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
One of my favorite memories...
From...
Anime Central...
Is...
Uh...
If you don't know...
The convention is very close to...
An airport.
Oh my gosh!
Senpai!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh.
Mmm...
Ohare.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's very close to the airport.
And so...
Um...
When I...
Went...
It might have been the last time I went.
But...
Um...
The...
Artist...
Main...
The singer...
Was there.
And she's the...
She's like the...
Voice of...
Cheryl...
In...
Macross Frontier.
But she also was like a...
Really...
Big...
Annie Song singer as well.
And so...
I remember...
In the concert...
She was singing Diamond Crevice.
Which is the like...
Kamisomani...
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba...
That song from Macross.
And as she was singing it...
And like...
In...
In the...
It was like...
The sun was setting.
And so...
It was really beautiful out.
And it was like...
Really sunny.
And the sun was setting.
So the sky was kind of pink.
And then...
Behind her...
There was like an airplane flying...
At that moment.
As she was singing it.
And so...
Like...
I was like...
Oh my gosh.
In my brain...
I was like...
This...
This is...
This is Macross.
This is so...
What?
And I just remember my brain...
That whole time...
Like...
I felt like I was ascending...
Into another dimension.
I was like...
This is the coolest moment.
I don't think I could ever...
Experience a moment cooler than this.
Ever.
It's one of those life moments.
I still think about it.
To this very day.
And because of that...
Because of that one moment...
Anime Central is one of my favorite...
One of my favorite conventions.
So...
When Ayami Sensei told me that she was gonna go...
When she told me that she was gonna be there...
She told me...
Quite some time ago.
So I was just like...
I...
I will go just for you!
And that was before they announced some of their other guests this year.
Which was like...
Soramaru!
The voice of...
Of...
Niko Yazawa.
From Love Live.
And also...
Gatsu!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the 50.
We have moved to a death transcendence.
It's true.
Gatsu!
Thank you so much for the 50 gift and thank you!
So bad, thank you for that.
Another 50?
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Larry!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you, thank you.
Sally and Maki too.
Yeah!
I actually didn't get to see it.
I'm so sad.
My schedule always overlapped with her, but I'll play next convention.
Going to my first anime con this weekend!
Wish me luck!
Good luck!
Oh my gosh!
But yeah, so it was just like... it was so fun.
I went to all the seiyuu panels and everything.
So even before... even before I knew that they were going to be invited...
I was going already for Ayami, so I felt really like, oh my gosh, this is crazy.
What's your policy for gifts at Ofukai?
That's a great question.
Thank you for asking.
Anything but food is okay.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Anything but food.
Well, that's at least what it said on the site.
I honestly don't mind snacks if they're wrapped.
But no handmade food or anything like that.
Asa was my first con.
I went to meet Ayasuzaki and got her to sign my Nitta Minami CD.
Oh my god!
I had a lot of fun even though I went alone.
Yeah, sometimes things like that are so fun, even alone.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
Thank you for one month...
GIFT!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you guys.
But...
But yeah...
So gifts are okay.
Which I think...
Um...
Uh...
Am I allowed to say this?
Um...
Uh...
It will be like my first time receiving gifts so I'm really excited about it because...
Um...
Uh...
Back in heaven, there were times when people would give gifts.
And I...
Um...
We were told that we would receive them and I never received them.
And...
I think about it all the time because I just feel so bad about it.
How...
There were people that...
Were...
Were giving certain things or maybe bought something with their own money and then I just never...
Received the gifts so...
Um...
Yeah...
Uh...
I...
I don't know if like maybe...
Maybe if...
Maybe I'm still waiting on it.
I don't know but...
Um...
Uh...
Yeah...
So...
But...
Um...
Even from...
Previous...
Times to...
Like the...
I just...
Uh...
People would give stuff and then it would just never show up in the mail.
So...
I'm really sorry if that happened.
Um...
But...
So...
Uh...
That's...
Why I'm excited this time that I will...
Actually...
Be able to...
Be actually...
Actually be able to receive...
Receive it.
So...
Heaven's customs are kind of crazy.
Heaven delivery caught lagging.
There was stuff too that I was really looking forward to.
But...
Um...
Yeah...
So...
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
But I'm excited for this time.
So...
Um...
I don't know if...
Cause I...
I think for the...
Gifts...
It's...
Maybe only for people that got meet and greet stuff.
Um...
I will try to see if there's a way.
If you wanna...
Yeah...
Not to say that you have to gift me anything or...
You know...
Anything like that.
But if you...
Um...
Want to gift something...
I will see if there's a way that you can...
Gift it...
Um...
A place to gift it...
Where I will be able to receive it.
Hmm...
Did you ever receive your letters?
I did receive those!
Yes, yes.
I did receive those.
So...
That's why...
I thought it was strange that I...
Never got the gifts...
As well.
I thought it was strange that...
They just didn't include it.
And I don't know...
Maybe if it was like a lack of communication or...
If some...
One side...
You know...
If some place sent it and then...
Whoever received it...
Then...
Didn't send it...
Or if the...
The...
First place...
Didn't send it...
I don't know!
I don't know where...
The lack of communication...
And then...
Is happening...
I don't know...
I don't have any contact anymore...
So...
Uh...
Yeah...
I just think it's...
Kind of crummy if...
They say...
Gifts are allowed...
And people give gifts...
And then...
You know...
But anyway...
Ready to wave light sticks for you on Anime North!
Thank you!
I guess...
I guess now we know we can gift.
Yeah!
If you want...
If you want to...
You don't have to though.
Please don't feel like you have to.
Or if...
But even if you just like...
Want to write a letter...
Or something too...
That's okay too!
Yeah!
What's with the guy in the back?
He's having a barbecue!
With Snake!
It's Otacon!
I guess...
Looking at it here...
Otacon just looks like a random guy...
He needs his lab coat...
He's...
He's casual Friday right now...
Time to write a letter...
Why do you have a...
Why do you look so evil...
When you say that...
Label!
It's lizard!
Lizard!
Thank you for what?
The gift!
Gifted!
Thank you!
Excited and nervous to meet you at Off-Guy!
Delivered!
Why did you get a...
Did you get a meet and greet?
Yippee!
Thank you!
Lollipop, welcome to membership!
But yeah, there's been a lot of things...
I'm sorry that I'm kind of like...
Low energy today...
Because...
The weekend was so much...
And then...
I don't know...
The weekend was so much...
And then...
I came back and I was like...
I haven't thought of my schedule at all...
I should have...
I should have pre-planned...
I should have planned my schedule for this week...
So I'm sorry I don't have a schedule up yet...
And also...
Um...
I...
Uh...
What's the word?
Um...
Uh...
I can't...
My wallet is still recovering from Japan two months ago, even...
So even though I've been meaning to do ASIN, I couldn't afford it.
I think you'd really like it a lot, GhostDucker.
Maybe you could never go.
I didn't want to meet in green, unfortunately, but if you see a...
Zagreus cosplay with kazoos in his server school's mouth...
He has a gift for you.
Thank you!
Just finishing your podcast with Natara while cleaning my restaurant!
Oh my goodness, it's amazing!
You kept me waiting!
I hear a super chat!
Hope your Monday is going well.
Yeah!
Brain loading... yeah!
It was... just a really busy weekend.
And... oh!
No, I don't remember.
But yeah, sorry about... low energies because I'm just so sleepy.
But...
KC!
Welcome to membership!
Big ham!
Welcome back!
Happy to be here!
Otacene for life!
Yeah!
There they are.
My little guys hanging out.
Actually, I have them labeled as...
TheBoys.png
TheBoys.png We're chilling.
But!
We're not just chilling, you guys.
We're not just chilling.
Because...
There's something else.
Alex Mateo!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Mateo, thank you for one month too!
Media Post Con, life to be bleh.
I think it's just...
I feel...
It's really weird because...
This...
This ASEN in particular because...
Because I didn't win any of the autographs.
And also, usually I...
I go for seiyuu.
But I really love going for concerts.
And so...
The fact that...
They didn't really have like a concert that I was...
Super interested in so I didn't get to...
So I didn't go.
But I still...
And I was just kind of like, I'm just kind of like, like, I feel not unfulfilled, but I feel like I did so much and so little at the same time.
You know what I mean?
Sir Simplot, thanks for your help.
Sally didn't win any meet and greets, but I'll be here.
There are Ofkai hanging out and buying all the merch of my Oshis that I can find.
Your wallet, no.
If we can gift without winning, I have something too.
Thanks for being amazing, Vitto.
Thanks, Miss Miss.
Thank you.
Shadow Demon Lord, thank you for the gift.
I have something that we can do.
I have something that we can do, you guys.
While we chill and while we talk.
Is it okay if we just talk today?
My brain is really slow.
I can barely keep my eyes open.
I'm so sleepy.
Is it bloons?
No.
I wasn't sure if you answered this before, but are you okay with people cosplaying as you?
Of course!
If you want to!
I'm honored if you want to cosplay me.
Oh my gosh.
Good morning, me.
Good morning!
Good...
Oh.
Good morning.
Sorry, Glen German.
Minto time.
Are you guys ready?
Shoo.
Oh.
Oh yeah!
Hahaha!
Oh!
Hold on, let me refresh it.
Hahaha!
We're watching fish!
Which one should we watch?
I'm actually really interested in live spider cam.
Oh sorry.
Spider crab cam.
Let's see.
Let's check it out.
Oh!
There's music!
Wow!
Oh my god!
This is so...
This is so spooky.
Look at the size of that crab!
Why is it so spooky looking?
Why is their webcam... or their livestream not working?
No!
Okay, I guess we'll go to another one.
Let's try...
Let's try the live Monterey Baycam.
Oh wait, you guys can't see it.
Sorry, it's cut off a little bit.
Let's try this one.
Oh my god!
There's so many birds!
We have a visitor!
We have a new friend!
Sea otter?
Okay, we'll check them all out.
That's a big guy right there.
Is that a goose?
Talk to me, goose.
Sorry!
I just felt like a whiplash.
Like I got slapped or something.
Yo, what just happened?
Oh my god!
I thought this was supposed to be chill.
Me too!
Look how cute they are.
Oh, they're jumping around.
See ya!
See ya, loser!
See ya, you're not allowed on this little rock formation either, anyway.
Oh wow!
Wait, does it move around?
Oh my gosh, I feel so at peace right now.
If you don't know...
Oh my gosh, Dan!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you so much!
If you didn't know...
Before I graduated many, many years ago...
I...
I used to watch the aquarium live cams...
My favorite streams are Meat Zatsu's.
Let's go!
I used to watch these.
Just kind of hanging out.
Three years ago.
Many, many years ago.
The waves are so nice.
I know, I feel really relaxed watching this.
Let's go see... Some people said they want to see Otter Cam.
It's just little guys!
Oh!
They're spinning and twirling and swimming around.
I wish I chilled with you all sooner.
No, you're here now!
We're chilling.
What are you talking about?
You're here now.
He's so slick.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, he's looking at me.
That's me.
He's looking at me.
Welcome
back!
Oh, there he is.
Yeah.
Wow, there's so many people watching this one.
Two hundred people are watching this one.
Wow.
Hey, Aminto.
Hey, Doppo.
Thank you for a month.
Thank you.
That was so baby.
There's three!
I hope they're having an enriched life.
Will you be watching them?
Yeah.
So we just can watch and talk and just kinda hang out and, uh, you know.
Of course, if you want to, these are live cams.
They're basically 24-7.
If you ever want to watch.
It's the Monterey... the Monterey...
Monterey Bay Aquarium.
I keep getting these shorts of people that seem to have pet river otters.
Pets?
I don't know about that.
I kind of want to see the penguins though.
Is that okay?
African penguin cam.
Ta-da!
Eww!
Oh god!
It's disgusting!
Oh my god, exactly what I...
Oh god, imagine the smell in there.
I can imagine the smell.
Oh gosh, it's nasty.
The rocks are stinking.
Do not imagine the smell.
Look at that...
Is that a penguin right there?
I can't tell.
Or is that a rock?
I don't think it's a penguin.
Oh, I imagine the smell.
Yeah!
Let's go!
He did it!
He jumped off!
Did you see his little feet go...
tap tap tap tap.
Have you seen the live cams?
The what?
The what what live cams?
Here we see a group of poopy penguins.
Benny cabbage pie.
My cat just pissed on me!
Can I have some words of comfort in these trying times?
I'm really sorry Shin-chan.
You know they say sometimes...
Oh my god!
Is this guy...
I thought he was using the restroom.
You know some say that when you get when you get peed on by something it's good luck, right?
So...
Or is that pooped on?
Is it...
I don't know.
Who says that?
I don't think anybody says that.
Oh my god.
Oh it's...
bird poop!
My cat threw up in his litter box which actually rules.
I wish he would do that instead of the poop.
Everything about house vtubers are basically zoo animals.
We watch them frolic and play and occasionally throw peanut super chats into their enclosures.
It was funny after the the panel with Ayami-sensei
Her manager...
Ayami-sensei was like turn around my manager wanted to say something to you.
I was like oh okay.
Yes sir?
And he just like starts making like like he's like throwing a a baseball with both hands he like keeps throwing he's just like super chat, super chat, super chat, super chat Super chat
She was so silly.
She was so... oh let's look at the short cam.
Oh my god that's a big fish.
He just came up from nowhere.
Super chat.
No!
Damn it it's my birthday today and I'm dropping by to say hello.
Lei happy birthday!
I haven't been able to catch up with your streams.
Have a nice day.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for dropping by!
Happy birthday!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Lei!
Happy birthday!
thank you so much for dropping by!!
This is a super chat that allows you to react.
Super chat is baha blast color.
Super Chat is baha blast color.
She really liked the baha blast.
SuperChat.
Super Chat, oh gosh!
Thank you guys for the super chat.
Thank you for the peak!
Wow, he's so big!
Wow, where these guys come from?
Wow, how is it...
eat, eat
Wow, wow!
Wow!
I like how many different types of sharks are in here.
Okay,
good.
We have time.
Thank you!
Yeah, we're just chilling and talking and...
I don't really...
I'm trying to think of, you know, what else.
Oh my gosh, you can see the people walking by.
It's kind of creepy.
Now I'm watching the people.
Now they're in the zoo.
I want to eat sushi.
No!
Soul SS!
Thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Soulsssssssss...
Wow!
Oh my god!
Did you guys see that?
He just did a...
That guy just did a flip!
Hiyo, what's your favorite ice cream flavor?
I like cookies and cream.
I like ice cream.
Do a barrel roll.
What else do we have?
What else do we have going on?
Oh, let's see aviary cam.
Oh, they're so cute!
Oh, you can see the ocean from here too.
Look at that tiny little bird.
Oh my gosh.
This morning, my cat, Paz, she was looking out the window.
She loves looking out the window.
It's like her favorite activity to do.
It's her enrichment time.
Looking out the window and, you know, observing the world.
She saw, she saw, today she saw a lizard and she stood up.
Sorry!
Oh god, they were really close.
Oh my gosh, their beaks are kind of bent.
They have such interesting form.
God, they're huge.
They're really big birds.
But...
Today, in the tree, I saw the fattest bird I think I've ever seen in my entire life.
This guy was so...
fat.
This guy was just...
a real...
Wow, he's amazing!
Oh no!
Oh my god, it's so cute!
Look at him go!
No, cameraman, stop the camera!
Stop the camera!
Look at him go!
Oh, thank god!
Oh my god.
Oh, he's so cute!
He just won't stop!
Oh, he stopped.
Oh gosh, thank god.
He was starting to cry.
So cute.
Do it.
Do it, big bird, do it.
Oh, you jerk.
Oh, man.
Oh, yes!
Yes, yes, go back in.
Oh man, he scurried away.
He drank his bathwater.
Wouldn't you?
If I saw something that cute, I'd drink its bathwater too.
I'd be like, I need to consume some of that cuteness.
I need it.
Your boy, Steven Adams!
Thank you for the rose.
Thank you.
It was super cool to see you with Ayami tasting snacks in Chicago.
I hope Ayami passed along a little gift airway.
Yes!
She did.
Hey, cameraman.
There's nothing here.
Cameraman, show us the goods.
Show us the birds.
I'm in chill stream.
Awesome, man.
Ah, grain of sand.
What are you talking about?
I'm not excited about the sand.
I'm excited about the birds.
Oh boy, sand.
Where are they?
Where's the birds?
I think they're all dead.
Sometimes
I think about the world ended.
He's going around in circles.
Look how cute his little tippy tops are.
Tippy top top top.
Come over here, bird.
Is it possible to deliver you a letter at a virtual vacation concert?
That, I don't know yet.
I can look into that, though.
I can look into that.
There they are!
The birds are back!
The birds are back in town!
Back in town!
That guy was like a ghost signing.
Did Streamlabs' donor alerts break?
I think they're very delayed because of...
Because of the gifted.
I'm sorry.
They'll show up eventually, though.
I'm sure they will.
Eventually.
Oh, I see that some have been donated.
I'm sorry.
More bath water!
Oh, he's swimming!
Oh, he's so cute!
This one kind of sucks.
Okay.
Let's check out the kelp forest.
That's a lot of fish up there!
I typically like the ones where I don't see the walls.
Also, the way the kelp moves is really...
Wow.
At 28 feet, the kelp forest is one of the tallest aquarium exhibits in the world!
Wow!
Oh my god!
Does that have to be so aggressive?
Why was it like that?
Oh my god!
What just happened?
I got scared.
Me too!
What is up with this camera?
I feel so calm with the way the kelp moves.
Oh my god, that's an ugly fish down there in the corner.
They're so ugly.
That guy's ugly too.
That guy's cool.
I like him.
I like how he goes...
Fish shaming?
Whoa!
All the fish are coming out!
They're all coming out.
There's so many fish in here.
I want to see the school though.
Hey cameraman, can I please...
Wow!
He's huge!
Is that a parrot?
Fish, maybe?
Okay.
Wowee.
Goodness gracious.
Big boy fish.
Boss fish.
Bro was built like candy corn.
Oh, there's sharks in here too.
Thank you, Mr. Cameraman.
Hey Mint.
Did you know that recently scientists have discovered a super terrifying plant?
Its name sends shivers down my spine.
They call it...
Bamboo!
Terrifying.
Ever seen the Georgia Aquarium in Atlanta?
Oh god, sorry.
They have actual whale sharks and...
Manta rays!
Wait, manta rays are the really, really, really, really...
I know whale sharks, but manta rays are the really, really big ones, right?
You know what I like to do?
I like to go to the stingrays.
And I like to...
You know how some aquariums have the...
Georgia Aquarium is amazing?
I wanna go!
Been there a few times in the past.
I wanna see a whale shark.
I wanna see...
I want to jump in here and shove a fistful of seaweed into my mouth.
Might be a little salty, I know.
Good night, Minto.
It was fun catching your stream.
Thanks, Damien.
Have a good night.
I like to...
The touch...
The touch stingrays.
I like to put my hands underneath them.
And have them nibble on my fingers.
...
It's a good experience.
This one feels like a screensaver.
This one doesn't even feel real.
...
What are you eating?
Reese's Puffs.
...
Thank you Luke!
Thank you!
...
Wow.
I feel
like I need some more ethereal kind of music instead.
I love Mint as my GF and she has Boing Boing.
Are you okay?
Uh oh.
Get some help.
It's okay.
Jellyfish, that's done.
Yeah, basically.
Mint is with Ayami now.
Let her go.
There's the jellyfish music anime this season.
Oh yes!
I have heard about it.
I don't know anything about it though.
What is the...
What is it about?
There's a few shows that I've been wanting to watch this season.
That reminds me.
I have to watch Blue Archive.
Um...
I've seen this jellyfish stream for 50 billion hours.
It's my favorite.
I'm somewhat of an avid diver.
My most favorite moments are when I'm under and I get to see all kinds of sea life.
I've seen dolphins, some small sharks, and the most memorable is the lionfish!
Whoa, aren't those poisonous?
Do not pee on jelly stings.
I think you're supposed to.
You're supposed to pee on jelly stings.
If anybody in here got stung by a jellyfish, I'd pee on you.
So that you wouldn't die.
So don't worry.
I got you, homie.
I got you.
I got stung, Mint!
Help!
Did you?
Did you really?
Thanks, I think.
I would help a homie out.
Minto being a bro.
Homies would pee on each other to save them from the jellyfish stings.
Ghosts can pee?
Don't think about it.
Too hard.
Don't think about it too hard.
Thanks for the gift of every core!
I thought the pee wars were over.
Was there ever a war?
Planet of the apes.
Help, I've been stu- Tuna.
Tuna.
Oh, Tuna.
Mint, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Help me out here.
Spears likes the strawberry jelly?
Do you need a tampon?
Are you okay, mister?
Why do you use the strawberry jelly?
Do it, it's his birthday.
Is it actually your birthday, Tuna?
Strawberry jelly equals jellyfish.
I don't think so.
I've never...
Mint, please, it's Tuna's birthday.
Do it for the birthday boy.
Stop peer pressuring me!
What's the theme?
Maya went to do research before you...
Before I what?
Oh, pounce on the next doujin.
I suspect a theme is developing.
No, the one...
The one that I got recently was a hypno...
Hypnosis one.
I think I'm kind of into...
Into the hypnosis recently.
Don't worry, there's nothing else in it.
Minto, please say my name with contemptu.
Asni.
Oh no.
This looks good like a wallpaper.
I know, right?
That's why I keep it up.
Actually, recently at night...
When I...
Actually, hold on.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
This is kind of...
You're not gonna hear anything real quick.
I kind of want to hear what the music they have on for this, if it's like a...
Oh yeah, it's kind of like a...
Just like that.
What was I saying?
Oh, at night, I put on like a...
It's like a...
It's not a live stream but it's like a...
It's like a crazy stream.
It's a crazy like 8 hour long video or something like that and it's just of like, it's jazz and then it's like Tokyo at night and it just switches between some videos of Tokyo at night.
Akabane!
Welcome to membership!
That's my face!
What are you trying to summon, Minto?
Oh,
a snack.
And one day Matara offers to walk on us and Mint to pee on us.
Good day to be in the frame.
Only under extreme circumstances and you must... you must be stung by a jellyfish.
It's my good friend Bob...
Bob's birthday.
He got into an accident and can't use his arms.
Can you wish him a happy birthday for me?
I can!
I'm just gonna say Bob though.
Cause I'm scared.
Okay, cut that part out.
Don't tell him that I'm scared.
Don't tell him that I've been burned before.
Cut that part out.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Bob!
Can I get a happy birthday too?
It was in January?
No, you can wait until Jan...
It's already the middle of the year, you guys.
It's almost the end of May!
Next month?
In a couple days?
In like...
In like a week?
In like a week and a half?
It will be the middle of 2024.
Back when Sosenkyo was a borderline national holiday in Japan and Ailota would buy thousands of singles to vote, was this behavior based or cringe?
Was Sosenkyo rigged or not?
Thanks.
Let's see...
Hmm...
Um...
You know...
I have to wait until March.
Sorry, man.
Sorry.
I...
When was April 4th and you missed my soup bar?
Really?
I missed it.
Hold on.
Okay, I'm going to wish you a happy birthday and then I'm going to answer the question.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Solias.
Does the jellyfish thing need to be recent because I've been stung before as a kid?
Takeizo is winning the running, everybody!
Oh no, Takeizo.
I think you just put a target on yourself.
Okay.
Sosenkyo.
For those who don't know, Sosenkyo was like this...
I mean, I think they still do it in AKB, right?
They have a...
They have this big event where...
It's just a voting...
It's a ranking event, essentially.
That's all it is.
And you vote for your favorite member of AKB48.
And then whoever is in like the top 16 or is like the top girls in the group.
And they get...
And whoever's number one is the center for the next single and things like that.
So...
They haven't done Sosenkyo since 2019.
Really?
Shows how much...
Shows how much I've paid attention in the past couple of years.
Yeah, you buy CDs to vote.
Essentially.
And...
Also, I think you're the only person to pronounce my name right.
Let's go!
But...
So you...
You buy the CDs and you vote for your favorite girl.
And then you hope and pray.
And I've participated before.
I've...
Bought like...
It wasn't a lot.
I think it was like two CDs.
So honestly, I made zero difference.
But I...
The people that would buy so many...
I...
You know what?
No, I don't think that was based.
I think it was a waste.
I don't think that was based.
I don't think so.
I think...
Because...
You know...
I think it was...
I...
Yeah.
I don't think it was based.
Cringe then?
Yeah, I guess I...
I guess I could say it was kind of cringe.
And I just don't like...
I don't really like when...
When...
Something is like...
Just so solely based on...
How much money someone can spend.
I don't know.
It just feels like kind of wrong.
Like if I were in something like that...
I wouldn't want...
Anybody...
Any one of you...
Any of you guys...
Yeah, pay to win.
Basically.
Yes.
It's just pay to win.
And I feel like if I were in that same situation...
And people...
And like...
I wouldn't want you guys to spend your money...
To like...
Vote for me.
And things like that.
I just...
It just doesn't feel...
It just doesn't feel good.
You know?
So...
Yeah.
I don't know.
Like if that makes you happy...
Then who am I to stop you?
But if it's like...
I don't know.
Like...
It's just...
You know?
How much of that...
Were the girls getting?
And...
Especially for that...
For like...
So Senkyo...
Like you had to buy so...
There were people buying tens of thousands of CDs.
Like an insane amount.
Someone at Miku Expo Newark...
A couple weeks ago...
Paid me...
$120 for my two-year-old...
Daisenko 200...
With a broken strap and low batteries...
And a Miku insert film...
Because the official pen lights were sold out.
Oh my god.
That's...
$120...
$120 dollars?
I mean...
For a Daisenko 200?
Stonks...
That was funny.
But...
You know...
It's funny...
It's like...
Funny because I say that...
But then at the same time...
There are times when I buy a bunch of CDs...
For like a checky.
Or...
Like a CD or...
But I'm not buying thousands of CDs.
I'm buying, like, 10 or 20 CDs.
So... I don't know.
You know, one time I bought a bunch of CDs for a Kickstarter.
Well, like, I think they came with the Kickstarter.
And then I got, like, some extra perks.
Like, I got a video, and I got...
stuff like that.
And I got...
I got... some of them were signed by each member.
So... yeah.
But... I think it's... if it's like...
If it's for something like to get a checky for yourself, then it makes sense.
But if it's a, like, vote for someone to be the most popular in our group...
I just don't like.
I don't know.
I never really liked So Thank You, I'll be honest.
I just didn't.
I just always thought it felt kind of icky.
You know.
Ugh.
Pay to win.
Pay to win just makes me feel icky.
Not in this economy.
You know?
You can't do that in this...
It would be so bad.
Anyway.
It's only an investment to get them later and spread the word, right?
Well, for me?
I mean, yeah.
Got my first pay for my job.
Thank you.
Because you leaving heaven was the kick in the bum to me to leave.
Oh my gosh!
Really?
The fun plans.
I want to tell you my life is observably better because of you.
Oh my gosh, my dear.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Expensive.
Oh my gosh.
Fine.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Let's go to another one.
Wait, there's moon jellies too?
Oh, they're so pretty.
And actually...
I don't know which one I like more.
I think I like the other one more because the trails have like a better effect on the screen.
There's like more going on, right?
Oh, mangaka!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Gracias!
Yes!
Thank you!
I feel like I like the other one better.
I feel like this one, they need more...
But look at that.
That.
It looks like the sand dollars, right?
Looks like the design on a sand dollar.
Oh my god, I want to eat this.
Oh god.
Oh my gosh, someone earlier on Twitter, they posted slime that they made of me.
And I've never bought slime before.
But I'm gonna buy it and I think I'm gonna eat it.
It says do not eat on the package, but...
What if I just do a nibble?
What if I just...
Just one like...
You know?
Slime eating stream.
Do not eat it, Mint.
But I really want to.
I'll call poison control.
Will I actually be poisoned?
Oh no.
Pee in my mouth.
Don't do that, Emerine.
I think I regret saying that.
Let's move on to the next thing.
What haven't we looked at?
Did we look at the live open sea cam?
Wow!
Why are there so many bubbles?
You are alive, young lady.
Here it goes.
What am I gonna do?
Exactly.
Die again?
Mint.
No!
Don't say that, Evan!
Okay, I think this one will trigger some like...
What's that fear of the deep ocean?
The phastless foam phobia.
I think this one would kind of trigger that in some people.
Because the dark...
Like the background is so dark.
And you just see the fish kind of coming out of nowhere.
I passed my certification exam after work after studying for months.
I celebrated by ordering an IMAX figure.
Let's go!
Congratulations!
I knew you had this!
Mint.
No, don't say that.
Fish jump scare.
Do you guys have that phobia?
Oh!
They're zooming.
I was stung by tiny jellyfishes when our family was on a trip to the beach and it turned out the whole beach was infested by it.
Later that day, the beach was closed because of it.
Holy cow!
I've never had...
I've never had a jellyfish sting.
But...
What was it?
I remember going to the beach once as a kid.
And I don't think I got it.
But my sister got it.
My sister got sea lice.
Which I didn't even know was a thing.
Do you guys know that sea lice is a thing?
I'm gonna go back to the birds.
Oh!
Or the beach.
What is sea lice?
I don't know.
But it like...
I remember it caused like...
Hold on.
I'm gonna look it up.
Sea...
Lice.
They're little tiny creatures.
They're cope pods.
Oh no!
Copee...
Copee pods.
But they cause all these like really bad red bumps all over my sister's leg.
Sand fleas.
I don't know.
Ew!
Don't look at the pictures.
Copee pods.
Going to sleep but before I wanted to tell you I love you.
You're my favorite nerd.
Bye bye.
Have a fun nerdy stream.
Thanks.
Here you go.
Goodnight.
I thought Kojima made those up for MGS2.
What?
The sea lice?
No.
Those were different, weren't they?
Those were the...
What were they?
Fleas?
Sea fleas.
Are they real sea fleas?
Or they were a different kind of pod?
Remember one time a jellyfish spawning season almost destroyed an aircraft carrier.
I was on by clogging up all the cooling water.
What?
That's crazy.
But...
Sea lice are very tiny.
They're small, small little guys.
I'm pretty sure.
They're teeny tiny.
And then they get on you and they...
And then they give you bad rash.
And it happened to my sister.
Top Gun in the movies versus Top Gun in real life.
What do you mean by that?
How did you know I watched Top Gun?
I had a question about Top Gun.
Is there...
Do bird strikes really happen?
Is that really something?
Is there something that can like just take out a plane?
If a bunch of birds run into a plane?
Do you watch Top Gun every time?
Yes!
Yes, I do.
The carrier almost got destroyed just because sea lights clogged up the cooling water?
Sounds like a chill issue.
It's very dangerous.
Can take down even big planes?
Oh no, new fear.
New fear.
Rashes?
Oh sorry, we're talking about sea lice.
If sea lice exist, do sea monkeys groom themselves with them?
Spent.
Flammu.
N zeigt tijd du Look up Bash bird animal airstrike hazard.
Burden animal.
Warming up Itty bitty bird animal.
Lookup Bash bird animal airstrike hazard.
...hazard.
This...
bird slash wildlife aircraft strike hazard.
Wow.
Oh my god, this is so funny.
The picture they used for this is so funny.
It's like this bird looking directly at the camera.
A bird strike is what caused the plane to go down in the Hudson.
Wait, no it didn't.
Long time donator, pilot, or first time viewer.
A bird strike is actually what took down the plane Captain Sullenberg was piloting.
That became the miracle on the Hudson in 2011.
Wait, seriously?
Wait.
Bird strike.
No way!
Wait, I'm seeing 2009.
I remember hearing about this though.
That's so scary.
So how do they... how would like...
You know, you're flying.
What, do you have like radars that show where birds are?
Like how...
How do you avoid that?
Oh no, I saw that bird!
Look it.
Chicken cannons.
They fire them for tests.
I fucking looked it up.
They made a movie, I think.
Really?
Hudson River.
Two years ago.
Not sea lice.
Giant jellyfish clogged up the carrier's intakes.
They were being scraped off for days.
Oh, gross.
If you like Top Gun, have you ever considered playing Ace Combat?
People like to describe it as MGS with fighter jets.
Without how over the top the story gets.
I do!
Um, probably.
Once I get back from Japan, I'll probably start Ace Combat.
I don't know which one to start from though.
I'm still trying to decide.
But probably once I get back from Japan.
Because I'm trying to avoid...
Or...
Maybe in August I can start it.
Because I'm trying to avoid it with like some of my bigger events.
That I'm...
You know, if I'm going out of town or something like that.
So...
Wait, you're going to Japan again?
I am!
I'll be going to Japan again with Matara this time.
We actually have some plans that we'll be doing.
But I'll still be streaming while I'm there.
She and I decided we're going to be streaming every other day together.
So we're going to be like...
One day she'll be streaming.
And then, you know, you might hear me in the background.
I might be like, Matara!
I'm taking a shower.
Don't go streaming in the bathroom.
Stuff like that.
So...
And we plan to at least...
Let's see, what time is it now in Japan?
We hope to stream...
It will probably be a little bit later than our usual streaming times.
But we're going to try and stream...
At our usual time.
So we'll wake up early and stream.
And then go about our lives.
Another day.
But there might be also some night time ones on our end, so...
Hot tub stream...
She went to the bathroom, she would find a wisp with a jellyfish sting on the floor.
How would you get there?
First of all, I would say...
How did you...
I would say, where did this jellyfish come from?
I think that's what I'd say first.
And then I'd say...
Why are you in my house?
Shout out to Giri's house.
Soon to be Matara's house.
Well, the plan is that we're rooming together.
But if she wants to go to Giri's house...
More room for me.
I guess.
Why is nothing happening on this live stream?
Sorry guys, I picked a really lame one.
Let's go back to Otter Camp.
So cute!
The jellyfish was in luggage.
I've seen a girl...
They're here!
So many vids, thank you!
Thank you for haunting everyone at ASUN this past weekend.
Hope you're showered with gifts in the future.
And in honor of your cafe guests, here's a little philanthropy.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I don't remember what I was saying.
Rosa the otter?
You guys know the names of the otter here?
Oh wait, sorry.
I'm seeing if they...
These female sea otters are all rescued and non-releasable to the wild for health or behavioral reasons.
They play an important role for their species at the aquarium.
Not only as ambassadors to otter kind for our guests, but also as surrogate mothers for stranded sea otter pups.
Oh, that's so sweet!
Is your favorite scene in Top Gun the volleyball scene?
Oh my gosh, it's so funny because when I was watching Top Gun Maverick on this trip, I found myself...
I was like skipping through all the relationship drawings.
Which usually, I eat that up.
Usually I'm just like...
You know, I like to watch romance movies sometimes and things like that, like whatever, but...
This time I was skipping through all...
I was...
I was like, I don't care about you, lady.
And then I'd be like, get to the mission already.
Which like, I found very...
Different from what I'm usually like.
Oh my god, Robo!
Thank you for the very big akutoro!
I finally passed my defense and signed a job offer last week!
I've had some tough times.
Tough times.
Tough times, buddy.
And I really want to thank you for always being around and being mean to me.
Oh, by the way, I put you in my acknowledgement.
I hope you don't mind it!
Oh my
gosh, thank you!
And congratulations!
Oh my gosh, congrats!
I knew you had it!
You had it in you the whole time.
Oh my gosh, congrats, Robo!
Thank you so much for the really big akutoro!
Thank you!
That's so fun.
Oh my gosh, I don't think I've ever been in a...
an acknowledgement before!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, what did you say that I...
What did I do?
Uh...
Um...
Provided a minty, fresh experience.
Remind...
Wait...
Was your...
Was your thing on me?
There was a streamer named Doug that raised 300k for Rosa the sea otter's birthday!
Wow!
That's incredible!
They actually...
On the Monterey Bay Aquarium YouTube, they have a donation thing that says...
We get by with a little kelp from our fronds.
But you can donate.
It says total raise is $20,000.
I think I'll raise that.
Have you heard about the surfboard thief sea otter?
I'm not.
I don't know why.
Bite, say, sizz.
Thanks very much.
Thank you.
9 out of 10 dentists recommend mint phantom.
Absolutely.
Almost 4k...
Oh, sorry.
I don't look at the numbers.
Sorry.
Don't tell me how many people are watching.
Four people are watching.
Spooky number.
Thank you for...
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
I really appreciate it.
I'm not even doing anything.
I'm barely even talking about anything.
Mint type?
Oops.
Donned!
Thank you!
I'm one of the four.
It's calm.
Yeah, we're just chilling.
We're just hanging out.
And I'll... I'll change the title and stuff... afterwards.
Woah!
He just went through the tube!
Do it again, Otter!
Do it again!
Today was quite busy for me.
I was catching up... with a bunch of...
Actually, I haven't caught up with emails yet.
I've caught up with messages, I believe.
To people.
I had to pay a bunch of people because I was paying for like...
Art for the Patreon postcards for the podcast.
I bought some extra little things...
For Off-Kai.
If you are going to Off-Kai, if you're going to the...
To the... I think we said the panel.
If you go to the panel, you'll get maybe a little extra thing if you come early.
So...
Have the postcards been sent?
No!
I know, it's really...
Super duper delayed.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
We're going to be sending the...
First two...
April, May, together.
They will be sent.
Almost all the art is done for them.
But we just have to sign them.
We haven't met up.
She was...
Matara was supposed to come to my place.
My cafe at the beginning of the month.
And she didn't.
So...
We're going to ship them during Off-Kai.
I believe.
Since you mentioned it.
Can you show the tough times never last video for the new Wisps?
I never saw it.
Thanks for the stream.
Freaking ghost mate.
Again!
I have it.
I have it somewhere.
Hold on.
Maybe it was under here.
Oh my god!
He's crawling!
He looks just like Buta.
He looks just like Buta!
No way...
Oh my god!
That looks just like my cat!
That looks just...
I gotta add a cat...
Um...
Emote, don't I?
I gotta commission more emotes, don't I?
See you at Off-Kai!
I'm even going to the mate cafe after your meet-and-greet.
Thanks, Rude!
Okay.
I think I found it.
Oh wait.
Um...
No, these are all my idle videos.
Oh my gosh!
I didn't even know I had these on here.
There's videos of me...
Okay, so a long time ago...
Um...
My Oshii...
I would do like video calls with her.
And um...
You're not allowed to record them.
So I would record myself...
Talking to her.
So I would say, like...
I would set up my camera behind me so that...
But not enough so she could see that I was recording it.
So I have...
Oh my god.
It's me sitting in my closet!
Like back when I used to stream in my closet.
Oh my gosh.
I had no idea that that video was there.
That's so funny.
Wow.
I also have...
Sorry.
I'm looking through my pictures folder right now.
Which I don't have a ton of stuff in here.
But I do have a lot of stuff in here.
But I have a folder called Google Earth VR.
And the only...
I don't know why I have this.
The only thing I have in here is...
ShuangGao.
But I think it's upside down.
And also...
It's called ShuangGao.jpeg.
Did I take this?
Shuang...
I don't know why I have this.
I don't even remember using Google Earth VR.
Okay.
I'm still looking for the video.
It's not under videos.
Maybe...
I still have to open the door of my microwave.
It'll turn on automatically while it's open.
Do you think it's a ghost?
Wait.
It's turning on while the door is open?
I think you need to throw that away.
I think you need to disassemble that.
I think that's not safe.
I think that's pretty bad.
You put your ShuangGao away, young man.
Sorry.
Have you ever gone flying upside down over the German countryside?
Apparently, I have in VR.
You know...
I can't keep still.
I'm probably going to die.
I know I'm, like, crazy, out of control, wild.
Where could it be?
I thought it was under here.
Wait.
What is this?
I don't know.
Somebody stop her.
Now this is going to drive me crazy.
This is crazy though.
This is going to drive me crazy.
You know what?
I just had an idea.
I had an idea for people who can't make it to the meet and greet.
Maybe, maybe.
If I can't find the video today, I'll find it eventually and then I'll show it eventually.
Sorry.
I really have no idea where it's at.
Where it's at.
But I saw it recently.
Wait, that means the other videos that were in there are gone too.
No, where's all my stuff?
Idea?
A VR meetup?
Stop spoiling it!
What if we meet in VR chat?
But I don't have a model.
I don't have a 3D model I could use.
Please, I lost the meet and greet.
You don't need a meet and greet to meet me.
Frog model?
Would you love me even if I'm a frog?
What is this guy doing over here in the corner?
He's like circling around with his tail.
What is he doing?
I think he's playing.
You're only gonna love me if I'm a frog.
I'd even love you more if you were a frog.
I would love you more if you were a frog.
Do I need to get a frog outfit?
I was thinking about that though I was like, what kind of outfits do I want?
I already have my next outfit plans.
So you can't choose that one.
I was like, what kind of outfits do I want?
But, maybe in the future, if you guys ever want to give me ideas for a third outfit.
Who knows.
Ghost made bikini.
That was so fast.
That was so...
That was so like...
Here's my chance.
Swimsuit.
I thanked my friend Mint for unconditional emotional support.
I haven't come out as a weeb yet.
I was too shy to say my Oshii.
You're a weeb!
Oh my gosh.
I've reached peak weeb levels, everybody.
I have reached...
I have reached extreme weeb levels that cannot be...
Undone, I believe.
Which, I mean, is pretty...
Kermit the frog.
Which are like...
Okay, first of all...
When I was...
When I was waiting to go home, I was getting food.
And I got...
It was like a Greek bowl.
I got like a Greek bowl.
And when I was getting my food...
The person checking me out...
Was just like, by the way...
We're out of...
And it was in a food court.
So they were like, we're out of...
We're out of spoons.
You can go next door and get chopsticks from the...
From the...
From the Chinese place.
And use those to eat it instead.
Thank you for the...
Phantom boy.
Phantom boy!
Your hergule floor...
Never akasupas when I can acknowledge it.
It must be really important to you...
To get the phantom boy.
I wasn't going to off-card because I was scared.
But someone convinced me to go.
Didn't win the lottery.
But I was drawing fan art to give to you.
It's Ben.
No!
I'm excited to go to my first condo.
Thanks for making me go out of my comfort zone.
Oh my gosh!
Amelia!
I hope we have a wonderful, wonderful time.
I hope we can meet somehow.
Got home from gym.
Very tired but productive.
Watched the podcast during and wondering...
If you're able...
If you're able to show us the pic of your two cats getting along.
Oh!
I posted it on Twitter sideways.
Sorry that the editor missed it.
But yeah...
I had to use...
I had to use chopsticks...
I had to use chopsticks for my Greek food.
And I felt really silly about that.
So I was just like...
Gosh, I feel...
I feel like a weeb in this regard.
But then...
When I was hanging out with Ayami-sensei and our managers and everything...
They were just like...
You know, Minto...
You're...
Are you sure you're American?
I was like...
I mean...
I guess I'm an American ghost.
Chu!
Thank you!
Yenway!
If my health improves, I'd love to go to a con and give you my Rex and Ray model kits.
Oh my gosh.
They're painted Itasha style with an unrelated Vtuber on them.
So that would be weird...
So would that be weird or inappropriate?
I might still make mint Itasha versions later.
I don't know if I would be able to bring them back without breaking them though.
I'd be so nervous.
But I would love to accept them.
Even still, if you are willing to part with them, I'd feel bad if you put them together and painted them and everything.
Nexy!
Phantom boy.
Thank you for the Akasufa!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
But yeah...
When I was like...
Oh!
I think everything's coming through now.
Spy turtle!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hey buddy, you're not welcome.
You're not welcome here, spy turtle.
This is...
This is an anti-BBC area.
No British here.
No broadcasting.
Finished making a devil's food kit from scratch.
Gosh, how are you so...
handy.
You have bees.
You cook.
Are you...
Are you a weeb?
How are you like this?
How do you watch me and have your life so well together?
But um...
But yeah, when I was hanging out with Ayami-sama...
Sensei's manager.
She is Ayami-sama to me.
When I was hanging out with their manager and stuff, they were like, Are you sure you're American?
And I was like...
I mean, I...
I don't remember quite where I died, but I think I died in America.
And they were like...
They were like, you...
You act too Japanese.
They were like...
I was like, well, I have like, you know...
I have family in Japan too.
But...
They were like, you act...
You...
The way you...
Your manners...
Everything is way too Japanese for you to be American.
I was like...
In my brain, I was just like, this is it?
This is...
This is what every weeaboo probably ever aspires to have said to them.
You have assimilated...
I know.
I am...
And I've been told before.
It's so funny.
I've been told before.
Like, one time I was in a taxi.
I was getting driven home by a taxi driver in Japan.
And...
He was talking with me.
He was just like...
Wow.
You are like, you know, Japanese is good and this and that, whatever.
And you like...
You seem very Japanese.
I think...
I think you are reincarnated Japanese.
Well...
I don't know.
I...
Like...
My past ghost...
You know...
It's kind of confusing.
I guess when you bring reincarnation into it.
But...
He was just like...
I think you were once Japanese in a past life.
And I was like...
I don't...
I'm...
You guys...
I'm a...
I'm a Japanese princess.
Sorry.
Hold on.
It's...
I cannot...
I don't know what's wrong with YouTube raids.
But the thing...
Look at it.
I have to screenshot it.
I cannot...
I think it said Nyaaru.
Thank you for the...
Raid!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
This is what I see when I get a raid.
Something's wrong with YouTube.
I can't see the name of the person.
Look at this.
This is what shows up.
Oh yeah.
I see it.
Nyaaru-chu!
Thank you for the raid!
I can't see the name of the person.
It's just white!
Thank you for the gift, Ducky.
Thank you.
Did you die by truck gun?
Who knows?
Sorry if I missed somebody's raid because I can't read it because YouTube is broken!
YouTube's actually broken.
White on white, Sasuga.
Um...
Yeah.
Everybody, I'm sorry.
Somebody coming in.
Hi!
I'm a Japanese...
Well, I'm dead.
I'm a mint!
I'm a ghost!
I died.
But I'm also...
Maybe I was once a Japanese princess.
Pre-incarnated.
And then I died again.
I guess.
According...
Two Japanese people have told me that I'm a Jap...
Well, he didn't say I was a Japanese princess.
I've had the white on white YouTube problem for the last week.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
It just started recently.
It's weird.
I'm like, okay?
Hi Roboc!
Thanks for the 10ped coins.
Thank you.
Um...
Yeah, I've reached...
I've reached peak.
I've reached every weeaboo's dream.
This is...
I can't go...
I can't go any higher than this.
Can we get much higher?
No!
This is it!
I'm...
I'm secret Nihonj- Look at him play with the donut!
Oh no!
For everybody also coming in, hi, we're watching animal live cams.
From the Monterey Bay Aquarium area.
Yes, yes, yes.
Wait a second.
Did I miss some?
Hold on.
Bloodlust, thank you for the...
Rogue Barabba, thank you for the 50 gifted!
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, wait.
Am I missing some?
Bloodlust, thank you for the 10!
Dragonuity, thank you for the 5!
Chris in the Box, thank you for the 5!
Thank you guys!
I think I missed some.
Oh gosh.
Let's go to a new one because all the otters have left.
Spider cam!
Oh my gosh, this one is so scary.
Also, it's broken!
They go here every time and then it freezes.
I think it's broke.
Aw, that's sad.
Okay.
Let's watch the penguins again.
Oh my god!
Look at all this shit!
This guy!
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
But this guy, I think, has had an...
Either he's molting or he just shit himself.
This guy needs a diaper.
Look at him.
He shit himself looking at the riaju penguins over here.
There's a couple here, there's a couple here.
And he's just looking on with envy.
It's even worse now.
I think it is!
I don't remember seeing this calamity on the rock.
And who did this?
Who pooped all over the rock?
It's sliding down.
This is so sad.
It's cuffing season.
And this guy is lonely.
He actually doesn't look too good.
I'm kind of concerned.
I hope he's alright.
Maybe he's like...
Maybe it is molting.
And he's like overly...
He's like plucking and everything.
Please, I'm eating.
Sorry.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh.
The camera like just barely shifted so that we don't have to see his sad, sad self, you know.
Molding too hard.
Never look up male penguins protecting eggs.
I won't look that up.
Now that you told me to.
I wish there were chinstrap penguins.
Those are my favorite kinds of penguins.
The chinstrap.
I saw those in...
In Antarctica.
But...
They...
It was...
Every time I went to go see them, the weather was always so terrible.
Javi!
Or Javi?
Sorry.
Someone said one month already.
OMG.
Thank you for one month.
Thank you.
Look at this guy over here alone.
Maybe you should try courting him.
There's one up here too.
We saw the chinstrap penguins.
Always on the bad weather.
And then...
Oh my gosh.
Adele... Adele penguins?
Was it?
Let me check.
Memble.
We are membles.
Thank you.
Penguins always remind me of my homie Grape-kun.
Yeah.
Grape-kun.
That's funny.
Yeah, his waifu became a Vtuber.
So true.
Starlet Yuki, welcome back.
Excited for the concert.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Me and a group of wisps are planning an Antarctica cruise for winter 2024-25.
Any tips or recommendations?
I don't know.
I would say...
Go earlier in the season.
Because I think that's when it's less crowded.
Like go when it's still like spring into summer in Antarctica.
Because I think it's less crowded then.
There's less other trips going at that time as well.
So it will be a little bit more secluded.
I think.
Get on a bigger boat.
If you want to avoid seasickness, yes.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
That guy just pooped all over the place.
No wonder there's streaks on the ground.
Don't do it again.
Don't do it.
No.
Penguin.
Please.
Is he laying down?
Okay.
Good.
He just laid down.
Primed and ready.
No wonder there's streaks.
There's streaks everywhere.
Penguins are gross.
They are.
Do it again.
I missed it.
Here I can wind.
I can wind the camera back.
Wait.
I think I went back too far.
Whoa.
There's even more up here.
Here.
Hold on.
Oh.
There.
There it is.
There you go.
But unless you...
It depends also on what you want to see.
Because when I went, it was...
The penguins are still looking for places to lay their eggs and start nesting and stuff.
But for...
Later in the season.
You can see the eggs hatch and stuff.
So it really depends on what you want.
You know?
You guys.
Poops refuses to elaborate sleeps.
That's the circle of life, baby.
I missed you singing live, but I went...
I wanted to say thank you for singing eyes on me.
It was amazing.
I love your singing.
Thank you, Starfan.
Thank you so much.
Fixie.
You welcome to my membership.
I thought this was a whole video.
It's a wholesome stream.
It is.
Wholesome.
Good dog.
But yeah.
If you want a bigger boat, I was saying, bigger boats will help with the seasickness during the Drake Passage, but a smaller boat, the more...
The bigger the boat, the less you can go out on to Antarctica.
So...
Thank you.
Choo.
Thank you, Murphy.
I was going to ask how long until she cries over animals being cute.
I wasn't fast enough.
Why is it because I cried over the bird?
Stop judging me.
I just like animals, okay?
I think animals are very cute.
Is this still the beach?
Yes.
Come on.
Shrimp week.
Love it.
Cheers.
I hope she's not tired yet.
I hope she's not tired.
She's on this.
Okay,
whatever.
She's on a break.
I'm hope she's not tired.
She's just enjoying the beach right now.
Choo.
There's a limited number of people that can go out onto land at a time in Antarctica.
So the bigger the boat, the less opportunities you'll have to go out multiple times.
Because they will be accommodating more people to go out.
And usually the staff is not so big of people leading people out of the boat.
So...
Yeah.
That's why it's probably better to take a smaller boat.
Even if it's the Drake Passage.
It's not as good.
I corrected myself.
I am judging and the judgement is on you, cute.
Look here.
I don't need...
I don't need you guys always going around and saying weird things.
And saying things that are not real.
I don't know why I just said real.
Marriage.
I'm angry that I just said that.
I'm angry.
At the world right now.
Marriage.
Existence is hard.
I can't even say life is hard.
Because I don't live.
I'm dead.
I can't even say life is hard.
After life is hard.
Words are hard.
And life is hard.
What was I saying?
Yeah.
Have a fun time in Antarctica.
Whenever you can go.
Whoever super chatted before.
About going with the wisps.
Actually...
Can I come?
Can I get an invite?
Because I just want to go back.
I mean, I don't mind.
I mean...
I just want to go back.
It's so awesome.
Yeah, just stuff me in your suitcase.
I can fit.
My ectoplasm is moldable.
You can follow in a rowboat.
She's only half joking.
It's true.
Oh my gosh.
I just want to go back to Antarctica.
Go by yourself?
I'm too scared.
Well, now that I've...
Now that I've...
I think the scariest part for me was...
Was...
Flying...
By myself...
In...
One of the countries I've never been before.
And I don't know Spanish.
So I was really nervous about, you know, Argentina.
I was like, how am I supposed to get around?
If you go, then 2,000 people will follow you.
We should just get our own boat.
Okay, everybody.
We're all gonna...
We're all gonna book the same trip at the same time.
Okay?
And we're gonna...
Share a DM for an invite.
Thanks.
Thanks for the invite.
Yeah, of course.
Let's all book the same boat at the same time.
And we'll just...
It'll be the...
Look at that shark!
Wow!
Well, I'll just go in the same one.
I would genuinely go.
Oh, that would be so fun.
Oh my God.
It'd be the best trip ever, I think.
Argentina, I mentioned it.
Come in!
Giant trip to Antarctica.
Oh my gosh, it's flying!
Come here!
Oh wait, I think he's trying to come here.
I think that's the edge of the tank.
No, we tried!
Oh, we tried!
Oh my gosh!
That was the best moment!
Finally something I'm near to.
He was listening.
Mamboo ship chartered cruise to Antarctica.
It's funny because I was even looking it up recently.
I was like...
What if?
When I got my tickets, they were...
50% off?
Or more?
I can't remember.
But they were definitely way cheaper than...
the price that they were on the website when I looked.
And I was like...
Ugh, paid.
So...
Hmm...
And I didn't even...
I didn't even write that trip off as a tax.
It's like a...
It's like a write off...
with a tax...
A tax write off?
I didn't even do that.
Even though I guess it technically kind of went for work.
But...
I just...
You know...
I misspelled Mamboo ship.
Curious what your best way to relaxing yourself Curious what your best way to relaxing yourself during con...
Because I know relaxing myself by playing games is combat.
During the convention?
During a convention, I'll go find like a...
panel and I just sit in the back.
And I just...
You know, even if it's not something I'm super interested in.
I'll just kind of...
Sometimes I become interested in it.
So...
Like how recently?
Um...
Like...
Maybe a couple weeks ago.
Like maybe like two weeks ago.
How many days did I spend at Antarctica?
The Drake Passage is many days.
The Drake Passage was two and a half days.
And so I was...
So...
It was like five days...
On the Drake Passage.
If you count there and going back.
And then in Antarctica it was about...
Um...
Six or seven...
I think six days.
Sometimes you just need to...
Chill in the backseat of a panel.
Rest your legs.
I know!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
Wait, I hope I said your name right.
I'm really sorry if I didn't.
But thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Um...
How seasick were you?
Not so bad.
I almost threw up once.
But that was it.
And sometimes...
Um...
Sometimes I would feel a little nauseous.
But I would go outside.
And the cool weather really helped me a lot.
I'm the organizer of that group.
Of Wisps going to Antarctica.
You are more than welcome to join us.
It is the opportunity.
Oh my gosh!
You guys have.
Like actually.
That's so awesome.
I hope you guys have the best time ever.
Bring Mint.
Mint to go.
Bring Mint somehow.
Bring my standee.
Or plushie.
Watching this gram stream like this makes me wanna go shout Fish!
Chinango!
Just like that episode of Rico Rico.
The little fish...
There he is again!
The fish that are like little tube worms.
Is there a jellyfish cam?
There is!
We can go back to it.
We were on it before.
This one's nice.
Yeah, that's the good stuff.
I'm gonna change the music even.
No, this one's too sad.
No, no.
I want something chill.
There we go.
Lamprey?
No, not eels.
They hide in the sand.
No, not a lamprey!
Oh my god!
The little cute ones.
That are like... they hide in the sand and then they come out.
I don't know what they're called.
Thanks for the fish!
Just great!
Thanks for the vibe gifted!
Chim... Chimpo eels?
No...
They're really small.
And they like always are like together.
Garden eels?
Oh, I think so!
Yes, yes, yes!
The garden eels!
Thank you!
Yes, yes.
Um...
They...
When I... I met the voice actress from Rico Rico, Chika Anzai.
And she voices...
Oh my gosh, my brain.
Chisato!
She voices Chisato in Rico Rico.
And...
And she...
I was getting her autograph and she asked me...
Like...
She asked me about going to aquariums and stuff.
Um...
And I was just like...
I was like...
I wanna...
Um...
I wanna go...
Or...
What did I say?
Hold on.
I'm trying to think of it.
Well, she asked me if I've ever seen the garden eels...
At an aquarium before.
And I was like...
She asked me in Japanese, obviously.
Not familiar with what they were called in Japanese.
And...
I was like...
Huh?
Because we were talking in Japanese before.
I know!
Chidango!
Shuji asked me about the garden eels.
And I was like...
Huh?
Wait, what?
She was like...
Have you ever seen them at...
At an aquarium before?
And I was like...
Huh?
And then...
Eventually, the interpreter...
There.
She was just like...
Have you ever seen the garden eels?
The garden eels.
I was like...
I don't know.
And I went...
Not!
And like...
It was so funny I guess because of like...
How much I was confused.
And then my reaction to her...
To her...
Like...
Question.
She like...
Bust out laughing.
And it was so cute.
And I was like...
Oh ho...
Ehehe...
Hahaha...
Woohoo...
And afterwards, my friends who were waiting for me were like...
Why'd she laugh that much?
What did you say?
I don't know.
To make her laugh!
What's your secret, Mint?
It was so cute.
She got into it.
Did they go to an aquarium in the anime?
Yeah!
That's why we were talking about it.
Actually, I'm going to be right back.
Is that okay if I go get some water?
You guys go listen.
Listen to the jellies.
I'll be like really fast because I'm just...
just getting some more water.
I'll be right back.
I lied.
I thought it would be quick but I was out of water.
I have a... how do I describe it?
It's one of those... I put water in and it keeps it warm all day kind of hot water dispensers.
And I forgot to fill it up last time I used it.
And so I was out of water.
But I got a little bit of water.
Delicious water.
Murphy, does your bank ever call you concerned?
Thank you guys for all the superchats!
Murphy, thank you!
Thank you, Kissraptor, thank you!
Gliss, thank you!
Murphy, thank you!
Flywraith, thank you!
Thank you, Mervi, thank you!
Thank you.
Thank you, Pikmi.
Murphy, thank you.
Vijay, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's so many!
Thank you, everybody.
Did you ever go to the fishes to ask for some water?
May I drink your bath water?
Hermocrates, thank you!
Yeah, I had to kind of rap it.
Kind of a rap god, even.
I think.
A little bit.
They didn't get concerned when somebody bought a bunch of laptops with my eBay.
I'm sorry.
Baja bla water fudge.
Thank you.
A kaindo.
Thank you for the gift.
I think someone else gifted.
Dog water!
Thank you for the 20 gift!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
What kind of hot water thingy?
I kind of want to get one again.
I know Zojirushi has one.
Right?
Let me look it up.
Zoji...
Oops.
New window.
Zojirushi...
Thermos, I think it's called?
No, not the thermos.
Water boiler?
Yeah, yeah.
Are you going to play Ace Combat again after coming back from Japan, right?
I'm late, by the way.
Either when I come back from Japan or in August.
One or the other.
Because I just don't want to be interrupted when I'm like, you know...
If I'm playing.
Actually, no, I think I can do it when I come back from Japan.
I think so.
Kind of.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
One of my friends is too embarrassed to ask you for a birthday song, so ask for her.
Would you please wish...
Skele...
Skelemon.
Skelemon, happy birthday.
Of course I can.
Skelemon.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Skelemon.
Happy birthday.
Having a Zojirushi water boiler changed my life.
It's seriously...
If you drink a lot of hot water stuff like tea or...
Oh my god.
Thank you for the...
Sorry, I'm leaning into the...
I'm leaning into the screen.
Thank you for the bread.
Thank you.
Yeah.
If you...
If you drink a lot of like tea or hot...
Stuff with hot...
Involving hot water.
Like if you make coffee, I use it when I'm making coffee.
Like it is so awesome.
Zojirushi water boiler.
It's so good.
So good.
So, so handy.
And then it's also like it just keeps warm all day.
It's awesome.
It's water fun.
Thank you!
I'm impressed by your pronunciation.
Almost no one gets my name right.
I thought it was like a Socrates, so I just, you know...
Looks like Streamlabs is behind.
I know they are!
They're coming through slowly, but surely.
I'm thinking of streaming after I move back out of my mom's, but it's looking like it'll be a while.
I might do it anyway.
When you had a roommate or parent while streaming, what rules did you have?
That's a good question.
I never streamed when I lived with my parents.
As soon as I could leave, I did.
Thanks for the button!
Thank you!
But with my roommates even...
I think because I streamed in my closet and it was...
on the other side of the...
of the...
of the house...
from my roommates...
they never really heard me, so...
I didn't actually have any rules...
Before... Even now, though...
I think... I think because they also stream a little bit...
We kind of just understand that this is just how it is.
So...
The live jellycam.
I know, right?
Isn't it awesome?
Streamer House.
Streamer House Rio.
Is the MGS episode coming before or after MGS Con?
I think I have it on the schedule for...
Let's see.
What do I say?
I have it on the schedule for...
After MGS Con.
I'm so sad right now.
What are we doing now?
I hope you're okay.
Stay safe.
Here's the list of play.
First By Order...
4-5-0 for story.
We can play...
Air Combat and Ace Combat 2 as your...
first game to dispute...
I'm not having a story.
Skip 3 if you want.
It's just set in the future.
Ah!
Thank you none.
4-5-0.
Wait.
I've heard to play 0 first though.
ne ee Ehe
Mmm...
This combat 4 is so good.
So much I want to play.
When will Metal Gear Delta come out?
When will Konami contact me about the dates for Metal Gear Delta?
I'd never play a Zero game first.
You know what?
That's fair.
That is so fair.
The chance of playing Ace Combat 7?
I would like to play it.
I would like to...
Actually, I really want to play that again.
I want to play Ace Combat 7 again.
And I really want to play Metal Gear Rising again.
Because I feel like...
Even though I've seen some stuff about...
Since Metal Gear Rising wasn't very long...
I can remember a lot about it.
And kind of think back on some scenes and be like...
Oh, now that I know the context for more stuff, I get it.
But I'm like...
I...
Probably don't remember everything.
So I want to...
Konami, please sponsor.
I don't think I'm big enough.
I'm not big enough.
I'm not in a company.
But even in a company too, you're not always guaranteed stuff, huh?
If I haven't finished Ace Combat 7 story DLC...
Yes, I still have to play that too.
Oh, tomorrow.
Tomorrow, I think I want to play...
Ghost Trick.
So we'll have more of that.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm still trying to decide my...
I'm still trying to...
Decide my schedule for...
For the week.
Still trying to decide my schedule for the week.
I don't know what I want to do yet.
My brain is so...
From this past weekend.
Especially because...
I don't know.
I sleep on a very specific pillow.
When I sleep at a hotel pillow...
Unless it's like...
Like the hotel pillows are just...
They're like...
I don't know.
My hotel...
No, not my hotel.
My pillow is...
The perfect...
I'm...
I'm Goldilocks.
It's the perfect...
Bit of...
Hard and soft.
And...
The hotel pillows are either too hard or too soft.
So I'm just...
Gosh, it was so hard to sleep.
I also met Chika Anzai at AWA last year.
She signed the back of my Chisato plushie.
Cute!
Her staff thought I wanted to sign on its pantsu.
She looked at the Takina plushie.
I hadn't asked why she got to wear boxers.
It's canon.
It is canon!
You're so right.
It doesn't hit the same when it's different.
The down ones are trash.
Down pillows?
Oh my gosh.
They hurt my neck so bad.
Why are we still at the beach?
There's nothing here.
Let's see what else.
Let's go back to aviary cam.
Oh my gosh.
Look at them.
Look at those little birds.
Walk.
Walk with your...
Walk with your feet!
The Kamiyoshi Minty Locks.
And the three pillows.
Minty Locks and...
What kind of a pillow is it?
I think it's just like a memory foam.
Or foam...
Kind of foam.
But it's like...
Has like one of those...
It's like one of those...
Pillows that's like...
Indented in the certain parts.
And it makes you...
Have a good support.
I need a...
I need a nice hard pillow.
Are those sandpipers?
It says...
Oh my gosh!
Look at them go!
It says...
I don't know.
I don't think I've seen any of those.
I think they're too busy blending in.
Look for leg bands on our birds which helps us identify them.
Each bird has its own history.
Most came here injured and can't live in the wild.
What?
They make firm down pillows?
I don't think...
I don't think that's real.
Kelp forest cam is always refreshing.
I don't know.
The...
That one like...
Zooms like crazy.
That one is kind of insane.
That one is just like...
Enhance.
Over here.
Wow!
It's dragging you everywhere.
Oh!
Look at that!
This looks like a nice area to live in.
I wish I were a bird.
Where's the kelp?
There we go.
Okay.
You guys ready for whiplash?
I've been to this aquarium over a decade ago.
I don't remember much but I remember Monter...
Monter...
Monterrey Bay stinks horribly.
Just the bay itself or the aquarium?
It's probably from all the bird shit everywhere.
Any zoo live cams?
I can check.
Let's see.
Wait!
Look at him!
He's spotted like a tiger!
Leopard seal!
I mean, not seal.
Leopard shark!
Sorry.
I got a little too excited.
Leopard shark!
Oh!
They're so cute!
Look at those spots.
Oh!
Wow!
There's two of them.
There's fish.
How do they all co-exist?
Co-habitat.
Hiro.
Hiro, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
The ocean stench.
Oh, the algae.
The algae is probably what's making it so stinky.
Maybe.
Stinky algae.
It all like gathers up and then is like...
A leopard seal would be a real fine.
Leopard seals I think are kind of ugly, right?
Aren't they the ugly ones?
Let's see.
Yeah, they're really ugly.
They're actually...
It's the parrot.
Maybe parrotfish again.
I'm not quite sure.
Spotted like a tiger?
You know what I meant.
I didn't mean to say tiger.
I also didn't mean to say leopard seal.
Okay, you guys?
I'm tired.
Let me... give me a break.
This isn't Tantorica anymore.
Look, when you think of a seal...
Is this AI generated?
Okay, I'm not gonna use this.
It's Adobe.
It's Adobe stock and I can't tell.
When you think of a seal...
You think...
Hold on.
You think cute.
You think like this, right?
You think like...
Look at his little beady eyes.
Look how sweet he is.
Look how cute.
Look at him.
He's just a little guy.
If you've never seen a leopard seal before, I'm about to ruin your...
I'm about to ruin your day.
You wanna know what a leopard seal looks like?
This.
This is what a leopard seal...
It's...
This.
They don't even look...
They look prehistoric.
They look insane.
Do you know...
Do you know that like scary stories...
Hold on.
Scary stories to tell in the dark?
The...
The girl...
This one.
Sorry.
Um...
The pale lady, I think is what she's called.
I'm about to show a scary image.
This one.
That's what they look like to me.
That's what...
That's what the sea lion looks like to me.
And then they're always covered in blood.
He's perfect.
He's cute though.
I don't know.
They look...
They look like...
So...
They look like a...
A...
They look so...
Prehistoric is all the...
The only word that comes to my head.
Like look at this.
Let's get rid of the lady.
Look at this.
That does not look like a seal.
That looks like a monster.
That looks like a dinosaur.
Dinosaur.
Mr. Night, welcome to Mambo Show.
That looks like a dinosaur right there.
Look so scary.
Their mouths are so scary because they have so many...
Like you think of a seal.
You think...
You think this.
We're just like, oh little baby seals.
Look how sweet he is.
Look how cute that guy is.
And it's just like BAM!
Leopard seals are so ugly.
Okay, this one's actually pretty cute.
Okay, hold on.
This one I'm about to show.
This one's pretty cute.
This one's pretty cute, I think.
Maybe.
Elephant seals are the cutest.
Let's see.
No, they're not.
No, actually they're the worst.
I have seen the elephant seal.
They look like me when I take a selfie.
Leopard seals look like he goes...
Have you guys ever seen an elephant seal?
I'm about to ruin your day.
I'm gonna make you wish you'd never seen this creature ever before.
I'm gonna make you think... I love elephants.
No, I'm not gonna make you think that.
I, personally, Mint Phantom loves elephants.
But elephant seals?
What the hell is this?
What?
What were you thinking, God?
When you created this thing?
On Noah's Ark, there were two of these.
And nobody complained.
No one said, oh, maybe the elephant seal...
This
one is terrifying.
You're so mean!
I offer elephant seals.
I wouldn't do that.
You'll be my .
It's funny because male elephant seals and female elephant seals are literally like video game characters, you know?
When like the girls are so like...
Oh la la!
I'm so hot!
And the guys, they just are like... they just have to be grotesque.
Like that's the male.
Female.
She's so cute!
Actually kind of looks like a panda.
Those markings.
This guy slurps!
But this one... this guy is kind of cute though.
This one is kind of cute.
He's cute.
He's looking... he looks kind of happy.
He looks like he's got a little bit of a smile.
Okay, I'm gonna show you something else really grotesque.
Gonna make you wish that you've never seen it before!
Gonna make you say, please, Minto, stop!
Put us out of our misery!
Put us out of our misery, misery!
Uh oh, the misery!
You wouldn't want to be this guy's enemy!
Doesn't even have teeth.
Oh no, he's got two bottom teeth.
Looks like my grandpa actually.
I never saw an elephant seal.
I saw a leopard seal and I saw...
Oh gosh, what are they called?
Hold on.
Types of seals.
Can't remember the name.
I saw...
Leopard seal and...
I
can't remember.
Can't remember.
Don't bully him.
I changed my mind, he's perfect.
You're just jealous he has a banging nose.
While you have none.
How dare you?
How?
I'll let you know.
That my nose could be as great as this guy's.
In fact.
I will!
You
won't catch me without a nose any longer.
You won't catch me...
Without a nose any longer.
Oh!
Vor!
Vor Vor Vor!
War, war, war, war, war, war, war.
Behold...
My nose.
It doesn't come off.
No matter how much I shake it.
This is how I'm gonna look for the rest of my afterlife.
Thank you.
I hope you can't wait to see this picture every stream.
It's never going away.
This is every... This is... This is everything.
This is everything.
As I'm live in this kelp forest.
Still don't see it.
Oh, sorry.
Don't...
Does this help?
Who sent that?
You!
What did you say?
Minto-chan is my saiko ichiban Japanese ohimesama.
Thank you.
Domo.
Banger nose mint.
Thank you.
That's the picture she chose?
With the mouth open.
Does that mean her nostrils are constantly flared up?
No!
Um...
I don't know what that means.
It means I might have an infection.
Looks honestly...
In my nose.
I think.
Oof.
The picture is worth a thousand words.
Yet zero no's.
You can't say that, you guys.
Look.
It's literally right there.
My nose.
Is right here.
See?
My neck is very long.
And my nose.
Is right here.
TVA septum.
My oshi is diseased!
It's okay!
I'm...
I'll go to the doctor.
And I'll recover.
You guys.
Actually, what if I told you that this was like my real nose job?
What if I got a nose job?
What if I got a nose job and I said this is it?
This is... this is the new minto... mintos... mint... min... min... nose... min... minos... min... minos...
What if I told you that this was it?
This was... this was my new look forever.
Is he a pimple?
No!
No you don't.
We would love Mint even if she was an elephant seal.
Where are all my elephant seal vtubers?
Rise up.
Rise up elephant seal vtubers.
I want to see long long noses.
I want to see the longest noses.
I want to see noses that reach the ground.
I want to see noses that touch the ground and drag all over.
Picking up every scent that could ever smell on the ground.
I want you to be always... I want you to be able to throw your nose over your shoulder.
Does your nose hang low?
Does it wobble to and fro?
Can you tie it in a knot?
Can you tie it in a bow?
This was a ploy to get you to show nose.
Now it's mine.
Yoink!
Have you guys ever seen that guy that like goes into the Florida Everglades and he's just like, Hey guys, I'm back in the Florida Everglades and I'm walking around barefoot and I'm looking for a 20 foot python.
Oh, there's a frog.
Yoink!
I love watching his videos.
Does that mean Mint is now open to accepting husband requests?
Whoa, what?
Huh?
Where did you get this idea from?
That guy is awesome.
I love that guy.
A nose like Ayami's chest.
Exactly.
He just grabs everything.
He does!
If you don't know what I'm talking about, I'm not quite sure about his username, but...
He's some guy.
He goes to the Florida Everglades and sometimes...
He went somewhere else too before, but he's usually in the Florida Everglades.
And...
He just walks around barefoot.
His feet are like covered in flies and every bug imaginable.
And he's just like, I'm out here in the Florida Everglades.
Oh, there's a swamp puppy.
And he looks at the swamp puppy and it's a gator or a crocodile.
I think the swamp gators or swamp puppies are the gators and crocodiles are...
He calls a crocodile.
Yeah, he yoinks frogs, lizards, snakes, and pet gators.
He yoinks anything.
He's just like...
Oh, there's a snake.
Yoink.
And like the snake will be like...
On his arm and he's just like, this guy's chowing down on me.
It's so funny.
I think if you probably search...
Florida Everglades, yoink.
I'm almost positive he'll come up.
Yoink, yoink.
I think...
I think he'll find him.
Now you're a seal.
Seals collect husbands.
But I'm the male seal.
I've got the trunk.
Can I collect wives?
Wait, the female seals collect husbands?
Wow.
You would think...
I don't know.
Seals seem to be like...
They just look like they would be territorial.
I don't know why.
The real Florida man.
I know.
High level Florida man.
That is the best way to call him.
Yeah.
He boops the dangerous spiders too.
I know.
He's just absolutely crazy.
He's wild.
But...
It's fine.
I like watching his stuff.
Especially because he seems so knowledgeable about each thing.
Because he'll see something and be like...
Oh.
That's a...
That's a Bebop McSpider-do.
Yoink.
And I'm like...
Whoa.
How did you know that was a Bebop McSpider-do?
Wow.
You're so knowledgeable.
There's a man named Thomas Wedder.
Slash...
Wadhouse.
Who had the longest nose of 7.5 inches long.
I'm looking this guy up.
Thomas...
Wedder.
Wood.
Mint tomato.
Your nose knows best.
Thank you.
Did I miss the otters?
We can go back to the otters one more time.
Otter cam.
Oh, let me get out of the way too.
Wait.
All the otters are gone.
There's no otters here.
There they are.
Oh.
They're gone.
I think I see one swimming under...
There he is.
Yeah.
I thought I saw him.
There he is.
Gonna get him.
Get that purple ball.
Nope.
He's just...
Looping around.
He's like...
Solid marine.
Thanks so much.
Just woke up after getting hit with work today and seeing the aquarium.
This is some peak as fuck content.
Can't wait to see you on Off Guy.
Thank you.
Show us.
Sorry, guys.
My chat is super duper delayed.
My chat is so delayed.
I'm gonna try refreshing YouTube.
Oh.
Bop,
bop, bup, bup, ba, ba, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup.
Uh.
Oh.
Never mind.
YouTube is stuck.
Uh.
Refresh.
Oh.
I lost chat.
You guys.
I don't know why YouTube has been so bad lately for me.
I hope it's not like this for anyone else.
I'll be here, bro.
I'll be right back.
Because it just keeps, like, always freezing and stuff.
Bring us back.
I'm trying.
I'm looking at you through OBS.
There you go.
I think we're good.
Thank you, thank you.
Kiss!
Oh, thanks, Sideways!
Your thing finally came up.
Your thing, your streamlabs finally came up.
I think we're finally... There's a couple more.
It's because it has 200 plus trackers, it loads for ages.
Oh, sorry.
100 plus trackers.
What's that mean?
Me angry?
Get it!
Run while you can.
Tiara!
You wanna fight me?
Spook or bottom right?
No!
I mean, I'm a little spooky.
I have to be spooky.
I have to be.
Someone asked about another zoo cam.
Let's see.
Zoo live cam.
I'm showing you now.
Pandas!
Panda, panda, pandas!
Thank you for hunting us.
Yeah, you know, I'm just sucking your life force.
Panda babies.
Look at the little baby panda.
Look at the...
Oh wait,
this is live cam highlights.
No, I want the real thing.
I want a real live cam.
I don't want highlights.
I want to be there.
Oh my gosh, this is so cute though.
Oh!
Even the cameraman was like, this is good.
This is the good stuff.
They're so cute.
I don't want live highlights though.
I want the real thing.
Stop.
I can't.
It's so cute.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Oh wait,
I think San Diego Zoo.
I've seen these ones before too.
Oh!
Oh my God, you guys.
Guys, we can actually watch people.
There's a guy in the corner.
Hey, who are you?
What are you pointing at?
Oh!
Get your picture.
Don't drop your phone.
Don't drop it in there.
Who is this guy?
There they are!
There's the...
Oh, he was pointing at the red pandas.
Oh!
Kvart, thank you.
The more you talk about Top Gun, the more you make me want to buy the Top Gun Transformers crossover figure.
What is that?
I don't think you're getting the shot, buddy.
I think that panda is gone.
I think that red panda is gone!
He's like, dang.
I couldn't even get the shot.
Oh my god.
He's laughing.
He's like, yeah, yeah.
I saw the panda.
Yeah.
You know.
It's more...
Actually, it's more orange than red.
You know, but...
It's behind the sticks.
I don't even see it over here.
I think it's gone, gone.
Show me the red pandas.
Hold on one second.
Sorry, I couldn't make it disappear again.
Let's see what live cams they have here.
You guys.
Tiger cam.
Oh.
Wow.
Baboon cam.
Are those the baboons right there?
I think so.
Oh my god.
There's someone in the chat that is really upset about this.
Let me show you guys.
Look at the live chat.
No monkey.
No monkey!
Oh my gosh, they should not go to the Tiger Cam.
Oh my god, they're gonna lose their minds.
There's monkeys here!
Monkey in the bottom right!
Hold on, I can entertain them.
Mute time, come to my stream!
Somebody help!
I've fallen in the monkey pit and I can't get out!
Oh my god, I've lost all...
There's a bird next to me!
I've lost all use of my legs!
Please, somebody help me out of the monkey cage!
Oh my god, I'm just a baby in the monkey cage, please.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, I hope no monkeys come down here.
Oh no, oh my god.
I'm just... I'm just...
I'm just in the...
I'm a ghost in the monkey cage.
Monkey... what is that on the ground?
What is that right next to me?
Is it a bird?
Is it a monkey?
I don't know.
The baboons don't want to do anything though.
Mint, no!
It's happening again!
The baby's blood dropped in the monkey cage!
They're gonna let these bloons escape!
Handle it!
Okay.
I thought I could tempt them.
I thought I could tempt...
Whoa.
Oh my god, I'm breakdancing in the monkey cage!
Oh my god, I can't stop breakdancing in the monkey cage!
Oh my god, please, somebody.
I just can't stop breakdancing in the monkey cage!
Oh my god!
This is not good!
Don't laugh!
Other way!
No!
Okay.
Whoa.
My bad.
Okay.
I think we're good.
I think...
I don't think these guys are gonna do anything.
Let's go to...
the live ape cam.
This is the experience I wanted.
No highlights.
Full disappointment.
I don't want to go to the live cam and say there's nothing here.
Nothing here.
No monkey!
Let's try the polar bear cam.
Oh my god.
This is the...
Is that the polar bear right there?
It looks like a turtle!
No monkey!
These ones streamed a year ago.
These ones are from a long time ago.
We could go into the past and see the monkeys of the past.
Giraffe cam.
Oh my god.
Wow!
Look at the birds walking!
Oh my god.
The bison...
Those are not bison.
What are these called?
I don't remember.
I haven't seen the new Planet of the Apes yet.
But...
Now I can't help but...
Imagine Mint break dancing in the middle of it.
Where are the giraffes?
Okay, I'm going to skip forward.
Giraffes?
There's a comment in the live chat.
It just says, why are they standing?
I don't know.
Also, why are they frozen in time?
Maybe that's what he meant.
Why are they frozen in time?
Why are they standing?
Oh, gazelles?
Is that what those are?
Rhino?
I didn't see any rhino.
Maybe I wasn't looking for them.
No monkey.
No tiger.
No nothing.
San Diego Zoo.
What's going on?
Oh my goodness.
Little guy asleep.
Why are they standing there menacingly?
Pizza mozzarella.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Red Panda.
We're watching Red Panda at 2 frames per second.
I love it.
144p.
Let's go.
Let's see.
What is that actually?
It's 480p.
Thank you very much.
Stop motion panda.
It kind of hurts my eyes.
Well, guys.
I have one last thing I want to check before I head out.
One thing I want to check before I head out.
And that is...
That is...
Jajangm.
Can we see Fuji-san today?
Yeah.
Okay, let's find out!
Can we see Fuji-san today, please?
Please!
I guess we can't see Fuji-san today.
I thought I couldn't reload it.
No Fuji-san today.
Unfortunately.
Let's see if we go back to like...
Oh!
This morning!
Oh my god!
Wow!
It's so beautiful.
Fuji-san...
A couple hours ago.
Fuji-san at the break of dawn.
Come on.
Come on!
It's a little broken.
That's okay.
There we go.
This is my favorite Fuji-san cam to watch.
There's also another one that I really like too.
But I feel like this one gets the best...
What's the word?
The best...
Good visual?
Good idea?
If it's...
If it's viewable?
But I don't see the other one actually.
It's not that one.
It's one from a street.
From a highway.
I also like looking at this one too.
Wow!
Oh my god.
Actually I have a recording from this one.
Because it was so pretty one morning.
I'm gonna cry.
Yeah, best perspective.
There's another one though that's from the road.
That I really like a lot too.
Like it's from...
You can see a highway.
And you can see kind of the lakes and everything too.
So it's really nice.
This one's so nice too though.
Wow, all these normies out.
Taking pictures.
Look at all the couples.
Holy cow.
Couple...
Maybe couple.
Wow.
Oh yeah!
Wait.
They're getting a picture?
I don't know.
Wow.
Gross couples.
I don't know why this one's not so great.
But if you go back in time when there's nobody...
YouTube is giving me such trouble all the time.
How is it recording?
It looks like it came from the 90s.
It's true.
It really does look like it came from...
The quality on it is so bad.
It says...
Wow!
There's a 4K.
No way.
This is...
This is it in 4K.
This is it.
This is...
This is Fujisan in 4K.
It doesn't even load.
Oh my goodness.
Doesn't even load.
Anyway.
Well, we kind of saw Fujisan today.
So, that's a win in my book.
That is a win in my book, baby.
Give me a second.
This is broken.
It is broken.
Would you do an MGS Zatsu with other indie YouTubers?
Or some who are possibly talking about doing it?
Oh yeah!
I've thought about doing something like that before actually.
So...
Yeah, I'd totally be down for it.
Oh!
Where am I?
Oh, here.
My bad.
Thank you for the chill stream.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for just hanging out with me.
Thanks for letting me just kind of be a little silly and watch live cams and talk about Anime Central and kind of whatever and whatever.
So...
Barbecue's still going.
Yeah!
You know.
It's like a really hit attraction at the maid cafe.
You know?
It was chill.
I'm glad!
I'm glad that...
I hope you guys had fun.
I hope you...
I hope my brain wasn't too silly.
for... for...
for listening.
Because my brain tends to be so silly.
So...
Hopefully it was okay to listen to.
I'll try and get more sleep tonight.
I got a lot of sleep last night actually.
But I think it's just...
It was my first time getting a good amount of sleep in the past couple of days.
So...
It was perfect!
The stream was great.
I needed a chill stream like this today.
Thanks silly maid.
Thank you!
Thanks guys for hanging out with me.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
I still can't believe there's so many people that will just...
want to sit in here and watch animal videos with me.
Makes me really happy.
So thank you.
Anyways guys.
Gonna head out.
And...
Yeah.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
And...
Have a good night.
Or day.
Or whatever.
And I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Probably.
I will...
Hopefully get a schedule out.
Probably not tonight.
I think my brain is too dead.
Tomorrow I will hopefully get a schedule out for the week.
But tomorrow is kinda busy for me.
I'm gonna do my best.
I'll do my best.
I'm sorry for being so unprepared.
Nan, thank you!
So there was...
Bala!
Thank you for the donut.
Mint plushies.
Hoho, thank you!
Will large mint plushies be made in the future?
Want to travel with Minto one day.
But if it's too big, wouldn't it be difficult to travel with?
Maybe?
Hmm...
David, thank you!
I miss Minto.
I wish chilling with Minto was real.
Nola, thank you!
I'm so happy I got the chance to be there and see you at Ayami's panel.
Thank you for being there.
It was such a special experience.
I'll never forget the day for the rest of my life.
I had a great time at the con.
I hope you did too.
I did!
Thank you!
Meep!
Thanks for the donut!
Gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for the stream.
Can't wait to see you at Ofukai!
Shoutout to Oymo for getting meet and greet tickets to see you.
Wait, what?
I thought Oymo said that she couldn't get the meet and greet tickets.
Are you being a mean person, Grump?
You're an amazing company.
Love you lots.
Thank you!
Nothing better than a chill stream with you after a tough Monday at work.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Can't wait to meet you at Ofukai's sleep house.
Also hope you had fun at ASEN.
Thank you!
They wanna fight.
Fight!
Oh my gosh!
Fight in my meet and greet!
Fight in my meet and greet.
I don't know how this actually works, to be honest.
I don't know if everybody needs a meet and greet ticket.
But it did say that groups were allowed.
So...
I'm not sure.
You might wanna ask...
Ofukai's staff.
I don't know if one person needs a meet and greet ticket.
And...
They need the tickets, yeah?
Because I was like, if one person has a meet and greet ticket and everybody just goes in together, then...
You know?
But...
I just...
I assume it means multiple ticket people can go in at once.
Okay.
Well, that's all.
Instead of a meet and greet, let's have a...
Um...
A meet and fight.
Oh my god!
M&F!
It's just like that game series I played as a child.
Meet and fight.
Okay.
Let's have a meet and fight.
Meet and beat?
Oh, wait.
Hmm...
We're workshopping the name a little bit.
Let's workshop the name a little bit there.
Please do not come to Mintos expecting a meet and beat.
Please.
Oh!
Oh, wait.
I can do this right now.
I can do.
What is that?
What am I looking for?
Oh.
Here.
You guys know what time it is.
It's the end of the stream time.
Oh.
The sound is off.
Yeah.
Baby.
Bed.
Bed up.
Something strange.
Sleeping in your bed.
Oh my gosh.
I want to go to sleep.
Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird.
Sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
I
don't know what it is.
You look pretty and I don't know that.
Coming tonight.
bad magic.
It's just the 73 Invisible man, sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'.
Bustin', bustin', makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah.
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'.
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Freaky ghost maid!
Freaky ghost man!
Freaky man baby!
If you're all alone, let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good!
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
Except the ones in the hotel because they might have bed bugs.
An invisible bed!
Freaky ghost bed!
Yeah!
First
step!
First step!
I'm stuck.
Feel good!
Yeah!
Guys!
We're watching today!
Hanging out with me.
Welcoming me back.
I was only gone for a couple of days.
But I really appreciate it.
Thanks for letting me watch animal videos!
Otobito!
Bye bye!